- [Voiceover] Over the past two years,
apparel manufacturers
have worked to meeting
the revised federal standards
for the design of uniforms.
Then we have the option of no error.
So, let me...
That felt a little weird
the first time I read it.
Let me see if I can
pinpoint what felt off.
Over the past two years,
apparel manufacturers have worked
to meeting.
What we're talking...
Who's doing the action?
We're talking about apparel manufacturers
So apparel manufacturers
would work to meet.
Would work to meet
the revised federal standards
for the design of uniforms.
So, the error here is C.
Apparel manufacturers, this is plural.
What do they do? They would meet.
They would work to meeting
the revised federal standards.
So, yes, definitely
error right here, at C.